elle avait des bas qu'à chaque doigt des
tas de bracelets autour des poignets
et puis elle chantait avec une voix qui
sitôt mange là et avait des yeux des
yeux du peuple qui me fascine team
fascine
hier des lots waltz envisage pas de
femme fatale qui me fut fatale de femme
fatale qui me fut fatal on s'est connus
on s'est reconnus on sait père du défunt
on s'est perdus de vue on sait vous
trouvez qu'on s'est réchauffé
puis on s'est séparés chacun pour
soirées réparties dans tourbillon de la
vie je vais revue en soir à shanghai
ça fait déjà un fameux bail ça fait déjà
un fameux bas du band jour je l'ait
reconnu ce curieux souris qui m'avait
non plus ce beau visage pâle cette
fois-ci fatale mais murs plus que jamais
je me suis saoul et en l'écoutant
l'alcool fait oublier le temps je me
suis réveillé en cent ans les baisers
sûrement feront briller les baisers
sûrement fronde renault
c'est connu on s'est reconnus on s'est
perdus de vue aussi rebelle de vue on
s'est retrouvé s'est réchauffée visant
s'est séparés chacun pour soi est
répartie n'en tourbillon lary j'ai revu
un soir à java elle est retombée dans
mes bras elle est retombée dans mes bras
quand on s'est connu quand on s'est
reconnus pour quoi se perdre de vue ce
re perdre de vue quand on s'est retrouvé
quand on sait réchauffer pourquoi se
séparer
alors tous de voir leur parti n'en
tourbillon de la vie on a continué à
tourner tous les deux moments là c'est
tous les ans lassé
qui chante qui chante le tourbillon de
la ville de signée serge rezvani et
c'était dans le film